hello everybody my name is Peter pot ah
freak no um mark markiplier don't worry
about that whole exile thing everybody's
talking about that's completely made-up
that's not that's not actually happening
it was
I got hacked everything's perfectly fine
I am signing calendars and creating
content as normal see everything is
perfectly fine and as it should be see
it's Mike Mike the game I always played
and the shirt I wore while I beated a
bunch see this is completely normal and
everything is fine so don't worry about
it and don't yell at me for over
committing to something because I did
it's really not the case I promise I
will admit though that I'm sick so my
voice is a little less handsome now my
voice will sound a little more raspy and
deep and you don't have to worry about
anything
see look I'm playing the game oh there's
stuff right there
Oh No is that oh look there's the
animatronics just like in the videos who
could that be
oh look it's the channels mascot little
box lick tip tiny box tin what what what
are you doing here look my little
biscuit
he never was very talkative tell anyone
about the eggs I'll cut you
[Music]